more like hot joe jonas and sophie  turner have some honey fun-in-the-sun  it's great it's wonderful the newlyweds  headed to a luxury resort in the  Maldives after saying I do for the  second time judging by their pics what  followed was equal parts are an AR and  adventure Sophie called the vacay quotes  magical they ate sushi while playing  chess lounges and hammocks overlooking  ocean cocktails in hand rode bikes  through the jungle and had some fun on  the resort's a ginormous slide you're  getting a duck though the 23 year old  game of Thrones star and the sucker  singer first tied the knot in a surprise  ceremony in Las Vegas on May 1st a  source told ET that it was always the  plan to have a more traditional wedding  later on and that they did Joe and  Sophie formally tie the knot last month  in a star-studded ceremony attended by  family and friends on June 29th in  France  [Music]